dr maury vous êtes l'auteur d'un ouvrage
remarquable et peut-être même capital je
vous remercie pas ce qui concerne la
médecine puisqu'il s'intitule
soignez-vous part le vin cet ouvrage est
le fruit de 45 ans de réflexion du cul
périront surtout clinique auprès de mes
malades
est ce que vous avez observé des
réticences de la part des malades
bon très rare alors docteur oui un pour
chaque type de maladie il y à un vin
approprié yamaha propres grimpe à jambes
on a quelques exemples ici oui aux
hindous alors à 20,12 est un vin qui
sait qu il vraiment a indiqué chez lui
qu'on va lui pour essayer de remonter un
peu leur état de fatigue et de faiblesse
certains c'est tonique c'est un tonique
c'est un tonique
alors là le champagne on peut aussi
peut-être alors le chant le champagne
lui est un vin qui contient qu'une mesut
allaire qui contient beaucoup de
phosphore des éléments d celle de fos
des phosphates
par conséquent le champagne étant
indiquées chez l'individu qui a amené
muscles fatigués en particulier chez des
gens qui ont le coeur fatigués chez les
cardiaques qui font d'insuffisance le
champagne leur apportant un élément
tonique éléments nutritifs de leurs
cellules musculaires pas faire de mal
parrot ça fait pas mal
le bordeaux docteur alors le bordeaux
est un vin qui contient des sels de fer
fac la terre la terre bordelaise est une
terre riche en fer en ouvrant un comme
ça non par conséquent c'est un vin qui
va être dit steve à être surtout indiqué
chez l'année mais j'ai l'anémié pas le
fatiguer le déprimé ça peut donc tout
cas c'est bon alors ça d'autre part le
vin de bordeaux contient également des
hommes aux tanins par conséquent que
l'on tient au fond des antibiotiques
naturels serre ça peut en aucun cas
faire du mal ne peut pas faire du mal
seulement ça vous apporte au fond des
antibiotiques naturels qui sont contenus
dans le jus de la treille
c'est certes un certain c'est pour ça
que dans les cas de grippe donc lui fit
est à l'air n'est pas le bon temps dans
sa tête
dans un cas de dans un tas de cas mais
oui un tas de cartes pas et le blanc sec
le vin blanc est un vin au fond qui est
acquis sur le rhin tout le monde le sait
je ne le sait le scrabble le vin du rein
chef valurent un exactement voile on
voudra faire de mal
ça ne peut pas faire de mal contre les
yeux rapt n'est ce pas exactement qui
sont éliminés cette façon là le système
qui veut travailler les reins voilà un
petit on n'a pas vu encore alors tu
écoutes bourgogne le coup de bourgogne
là c'est différent le bon grain et à
mâcher lourd assez riche et c'est un vin
qui agira sur les seuls véhicules
billère c'est un vin qui agit qui fait
travailler la vésicule biliaire et spa
qui par conséquent est un vin indiqué
chez les pratiques
enfin c'est très curieux mais c'est
comme ça
pour avoir les pâtis il fallait ça vous
voulez goûter non non c'est pour un
monde contemporain vous rendez vous
compte n'est ce pas et ça ne fait pas de
mal en palpant de fois je constate un
petit point douloureux et le foie qui
déborde un peu donc bourgogne pour vous
monsieur l'indiqué de faire le matin à
jeun le matin l'autre par le rein est
également sensible projet puis vous avez
fait la grimace ici de mai muscadet ou
des pisse opinion également au cours de
la journée
deux à trois verres peut-être plus de
3,4 à mana l'a3 vers 20 juin pour
débuter dernier point un petit et un un
début de saison des râles donc vous
nettoyer au point de vue métaboliques
dans ces cas là wingles vin rosé de
provence également le soir au coucher 1
1 ou 2 vincent se coucher à chauffer
l'ordonance oui où je vous conseille
pour deux fois votre bourgogne 2 vers
agen pour les reins le muscadet ou un
vin d'alsace se croit verres par jour au
cours de la journée et je fait les frais
de ces biens étaient sincères oui
malheureusement ce n'est pas encore
remboursé
il faudrait pour savoir les ministres à
la santé publique lui demandait pourquoi
pas ce qu'est le vin n'est pas
considérée officiellement comme un
remède à l'horizon
qu'est ce qu'ils ont pensé à moi je
pense que ça devrait être considéré
comme un remède et que notre prescrit
médicalement est emmené les vertus
thérapeutiques de vin que l'on trouve
dans le donc la sécurité sociale devrait
devrait normalement le rembourser c'est
honteux qui me paraît tout à fait normal
c'est honteux
d'ailleurs marc à l'angleterre on
rembourse
whisky pour les malades qui a pas de
raison qu'en france pays du vin on ne
rembourse pas également un vin prescrit
par le médecin
il y aurait d'ailleurs beaucoup moins
d'alcoolique à ce moment un scandale
rentable il faut demander le
remboursement remboursement des le halal
enfin normaux à parle pas à part
par quoi du malheureux de remboursement
des 20 par la sécurité sociale
n'est ce pas c'est ça ce que tu une
revendication ce sens il assure qu'il
faut faire et je vous répète à mon sens
c'est la meilleure façon de lutter
contre l'alcool